a
[Música]
ah
durante la pandemia del cómic 19 en perú
con 15% de estudiantes universitarios
abandonaron sus carreras y en el segundo
semestre la estadística alcanzaría el 35
por ciento la federación de
instituciones privadas de educación
superior alberta que más de 350 mil
estudiantes universitarios dejarían de
estudiar por falta de recursos
económicos para remediar esta coyuntura
el gobierno peruano destinó 38 millones
de dólares para impulsar 10.000 becas y
3 mil créditos paralelamente algunos
bancos también promueven programas de
becas pero algunos congresistas
sostienen que las ayudas no son
suficientes y plantean un proyecto de
ley para eliminar el cobro de cuotas de
ingreso a las universidades existe un
grupo importante de estudiantes que
trabajan para solventar sus estudios
pero el 30% de jóvenes peruanos
perdieron sus empleos durante la
pandemia según en un estudio de la
fundación forge la eventualidad ha
propiciado que la cantidad de chicas y
chicos que no estudian ni trabajan- se
amplíe por eso diversos colectivos
reclaman una educación justa y
equitativa señalan que un mejor nivel
educativo reduce sustancialmente las
probabilidades de
caer en situaciones de pobreza
[Música]
irán ha comenzado este nuevo año
académico en un momento en el que el
gobierno ha aceptado que está llegando
la tercera hora de kobe 19 la
inauguración del año universitario hecho
por el presidente a sandro hand y habló
de que parte de la carrera del azul de
las clases se iban dar por internet pero
muchas también se darían presenciales y
esto pone en un mayor dilema a las
universidades que ya se dieron en
problemas en marzo pasado cuando
cerraron las aulas primero porque no
estaban preparadas para dar clases por
internet segundo porque muchísimos
estudiantes no tenían acceso al internet
especialmente en áreas más alejadas del
país y tercero porque los profesores no
tenían el conocimiento esto llevó a que
muchos estudiantes decidieran cancelar o
congelar el último semestre del año
pasado y después de muchos días dudas el
ministerio de ciencias decidió aceptarlo
por motivos especiales pero se conoce
que este año vuelve a suceder lo mismo
muchos estudiantes quieren congelar la
carrera primero porque no tiene las
condiciones de internet y segundo porque
no se ven en capacidad de regresar a las
aulas en un momento en el que el cob y
19 sigue afectando al país
[Música]
a lo largo del mes de septiembre tiene
lugar en españa la segunda convocatoria
de las pruebas de acceso a la
universidad y por lo tanto también la
segunda tanda de inscripciones
universitarias por lo que no disponemos
todavía de una imagen fija sobre si han
podido disminuir las matriculaciones
debido a la crisis económica ligada al
coronavirus pero por otro lado la lucha
para que a disminuyan las tasas
universitarias tiene años de recorrido
en el movimiento estudiantil y es algo
que está previsto por el actual
ejecutivo pero por lo que todavía hay un
par de años de margen de ejecución pero
por otro lado también el gobierno
decretó esta primavera un aumento de más
del 20 por ciento del presupuesto para
las becas de educación y universidades
pero hay que tener en cuenta que estas
ayudas se calculan en base a las rentas
familiares de los últimos dos años por
lo tanto las familias que hayan visto
decrecer su capital económico
exclusivamente en función de la
situación actual no van a ser
beneficiarias de estas ayudas
[Música]